winter is here well it's finally arrived
final season of Game of Thrones the
premiere episode of season 8 shows back
I've got a shirt that Liz gave me for my
birthday
so I a little bit later than I planned
but I have now seen Winterfell first
episode of the new season it's a little
dull now I came in I came out I suppose
of having watched it you know thinking
that and I didn't want to just come back
just spit that out so I've been spending
the last couple hours before shooting
this actually trying to think why do I
feel that and is it justified and here's
where I'm landing I do kind of stand by
that impression this premiere episode is
a little dull and there's a couple of
reasons for that that kind of can't be
helped actually if you go back a fair
number of early if not first
it's the episodes of most seasons are a
little dull including season 1 but
season 1 got away with it because it was
still setting up everything but the
premiere episodes tend to be a lot of
housekeeping a lot of here's where
everybody is and here's us moving them
to where they need to be so we can get
the story really properly kicked off
first episodes for this show don't
usually open big and bold they're about
moving the pieces into the right place
so that's the first thing and I'm not
sure there's a huge way around that the
other thing that the episode is stuck
doing is basically catching up a bunch
of characters on stuff we the audience
already knew ie a whole bunch of
characters reencounter someone who they
haven't seen in a while and in many
cases thought was dead and now yeah and
of course we've known they've been alive
or you know the stuff about I was gonna
say spoilers except this came of last
season so like I'm gonna talk spoilers
in these reviews just know that
um the whole thing with jon snow's
parentage the fact that he's actually a
Targaryen we the audience already knew
that we got to catch them up so it can
also be a little bit dull when you're
waiting for the characters to figure out
what you already know now those are the
things that can't really be helped but I
think there's a little more than that
going on as to why I kind of felt like
this was not borings too harsh but like
didn't thrill me and I think another
thing is what's left to be done I don't
find engaging in the way that the best
of this show has been because as much as
the overall threat of the night King the
White Walkers I mean that's that's
always been hanging over things and that
was always a good thing to have in the
background as a you know as a sort of
Damocles kind of hanging over everything
most of the threats that aren't that are
gone and the ones that are still around
aren't in the location where everyone
else is so like at this point basically
the major threat that isn't the White
Walkers is seriously now I suppose you
could also consider Euron because he's
kind of aligned with her at this point
but it also takes some attention out of
it to know that they are physically on
the other side of the continent so I I
think in some ways it's in terms of
keeping things interesting as we build
to what will I'm sure will be an epic
climactic actual fight with the night
king and everything else the things that
that could be going on to keep things
interesting as we get there there isn't
a lot at play right now
so like dealing with characters like
Ramsay Bolton like Littlefinger that was
really good for keeping things
interesting while we're you know keeping
is taking over until we get to the
really big fight that's going on but
they're all off the board
and I also kind of worried a little bit
because I'm not sure that dealing with
the night King can possibly be as
cathartic as something like the death of
Littlefinger cuz yeah that felt good
I mean maybe if they do seriously right
cuz there's no way seriously lose
through this no way so when she
eventually dies you know that could
possibly be cathartic and for my money
I've said this before I'll say it again
Jamie's gonna gotta be the one to kill
her but having now done dumb things in
reverse order having done my complaining
and my worries up front there was still
stuff that I really enjoyed here some of
the reunions of characters were really
nice Arya I think had the best ones I
think hers with John was really good her
and the Hound her and Gendry was she
flirting with him seemed like she might
have been in any case arias just got
great chemistry would like everybody
Sansa and Tyrion that was actually a
pretty cool reunion - I had forgotten
how long it had been since they seen
each other so that that was cool I like
that I kind of as much as like I'm over
the shows you know completely
unnecessary nude scenes I did kind of
love bran with his three women you know
just try to have fun and they want to
talk to him about fighting a dragon and
then he's interrupted by the end of the
Queen this guy just wants to have a nice
life that's all he wants uh I love bran
a lot um Lyanna Mormont she oh god she's
so tough
well I I I have no reasonable
expectation that this happens but like
if the Iron Throne even still exists at
the end of this which I don't think it
will I want her to end up on it but you
know so she's really good Sansa like
I have to give my Maricopa eye Sansa has
become a really interesting and
fascinating character and one that I'm
excited to see and given that I used to
hate her like I mean this is right up
there with how I turned around on
Barbara and Gotham cuz season 1 I hated
Barbara now she's like I'm like there's
never enough Barbara so I I have to
admit that to sense that I I did Sansa
wrong and in her earlier appearances
because she's oh she's good she's really
good me and her evolution has been has
been quite enjoyable Fionna actually
gets some cool little I was I was gonna
say redemptive that's but that's that's
a little pre-emptive to declare at a
Redemption let's go with Redemption
adjacent moments with him you know
rescuing his sister and all of that so I
as much as this episode is mostly kind
of just moving the pieces to where they
need to be I like the pieces and some of
them interact pretty well Oh Sam I have
legitimately forgotten that Danny he
burnt his dad and his brother to an
absolute crisp I totally forgotten that
and that actor played that really well
the the surprise and then the pain of
that I I was impressed um and also I
kind of liked the moment they chose to
end it on I like the the symmetry of it
with season 1 because and actually the
episode overall and I'll give a certain
amount of cleverness for this I'm not
sure you know because like I said I
think the results are slightly dull I'm
not sure it was necessarily the right
call but I kind of appreciate what they
were going for overall this episode
feels like almost like a poetic reprise
of season 1 episode 1 because we open
with
the you know the the armies the the the
soldiers marching into Winterfell and
you know younger characters trying to
see and you know a whole lot of it just
talking about who owes old allegiance -
who who's gonna support who in what and
what the worries are and what the
history is and so we it's it's that vibe
in both episodes and then for the fact
that season 1 episode 1 ended with Jamie
shoving bran
I'm sorry not bran brand out of window
and this episode ends with Jamie showing
up in Winterfell
it actually was really funny because I
remember thinking boy yeah it's a good
thing it's not modern times for him
we're like his his face would be in like
tabloids or on on the news or whatever
probably no one's gonna recognize him as
long as he keeps his head down and then
he looks he turns around
there's Bram just staring at him
the look on Jamie's face the oh look
there's uh there is a nice symmetry to
that comparing to the very first episode
of the show and I will be curious to see
what happens from here and I'm hoping
it's something good because specifically
with that because loss of gods and men
might be my favorite episode that's
tyrians trial so I I like those kinds of
things and I think there's the potential
for that with Jamie being captured in
Winterfell and and offices all there's
characters that I'm basically like still
waiting to properly touch base with like
Brienne like she was just standing
behind Sansa reminding us all how tall
she is I want to see what happens when
Brienne runs into the Hound that's what
I'm waiting on right now but I think
we'll wrap it up there it was by no
means an exciting opening it got the job
done
it's not especially memorable
but let's see where they can go from
here
so winterfell Game of Thrones Season
eight episode 1 what do you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down on the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of other stuff
down there because there's buttons and
links and link to my book and there's
social media and there's patreon much
appreciated but that's all down there
for you to take a look at but you also
don't really have to because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the meetings so until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]